[Music]
foreign
view a first look at what is on the
front pages time there to see what's
making the headlines with the political
editors of the guardian and the sum
papakura and Harry Cole with us from now
until just before midnight welcome to
both of you so from Pages let's start
shall we with the financial times which
reports on President Joe Biden's
unannounced visit to the Ukrainian
Capital Kiev in which he pledged
America's unwavering support to the
war-torn country
the telegraph says former Prime
Ministers Boris Johnson and Liz truss
have urged their successor Rishi sunak
to send fighter jets to Ukraine
as it's confirmed the body found in the
river wire was that of the missing
mother of two Nicola bully the eye has
word of her family's criticism of TV and
social media coverage of the case
the express quotes from the bully's
family statement Nikki we can let you
rest now
while the sun carries a similar headline
on its front page
and the Daily Mail follows suit with a
similar sentiment
The Daily Mirror leads with the family's
description of Nicola she was the center
of our world
the Metro meanwhile leads with the
announcement of a 72-hour strike by
Junior doctors coming in March
the guardian reporting on the
catastrophic failings in the management
of a policing Firearms unit which
contributed to the mass shooting in
Plymouth in which gunman Jake Davidson
killed five people
the time says Rishi sunak has been
warned that any deal he does on the
Northern Ireland brexit protocol could
lead to potty resignations
and the star bemoans the watering down
of language in certain passages of new
editions of Roald Dahl's books which the
Prime Minister has also now criticized
while it reminded by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
while you watch us so let's head
straight to papakura and Harry Cole and
Harry we see the arrival are now tonight
in Warsaw of President Joe Biden after
this unannounced visit to Ukraine from
page of the financial times with some
extraordinary pictures and possibly
um you know a sense that we might never
see this arrival of these two presidents
together
yeah well obviously um zielinski
traveled the first place he ever
traveled post-invasion was the United
States in a equally sort of secret trip
a few months ago but a remarkable
um image there if you think about the
sort of cavalcade that the uh the
American president usually travels with
I remember when he rolled through Dan
White who I think I counted 17 cars uh
ambulances you know mobile operating
theaters
a small army of bodyguards uh and to
take that that circus I suppose to to
what is essentially a war zone still is
a war zone even if Kiev isn't directly
attacked every day it is you know a
Target
um it's remarkable and a a a brilliant
display of of unity and a pretty brave
move I'd say by Biden um imagine the
Secret Service we're having absolute
kittens by this when he was announcing
he was going to travel to Poland a few
people thought well maybe he might just
do it
um and then when Bridges and motorways
and uh and train lines were all shut
down overnight in around cave then sort
of speculation grew but actual
remarkable image to see him there and so
walking through the air raid sirens yes
and I don't know about you but I had a
sense of relief on on understanding that
Russia had been warned about this in
advance
um you know you you dread to think what
might have happened should there been
some accident uh but certainly Jake
Sullivan the U.S national security
adviser who also traveled to the two
presidents sought to map out the coming
year including a common understanding of
objectives and how the US can most
effectively support them alongside our
allies and partners certainly we're
standing with you for the future about
mapping out the next year you know
there's no end in sight to this pepper
and that's part of the problem isn't it
yeah and certainly as far as U.S support
for the conflict goes Biden was um
unequivocal that um he would that the
U.S would it was unwavering in its
support and that would continue but it's
hard not to
um to ignore some of the uh voices in
America which are
um are really sort of adding pressure to
him now I mean the U.S Administration
announced 500 million dollars of new Aid
uh new lethal Aid to Ukraine today
that's on top of or that takes the total
to to
um to tens of billions upon 30 billion
pounds sorry dollars
um since uh the invasion of Russian
invasion last year and Republican voices
and of course lots of this would have to
go through um Congress uh if there was
going to be more support more financial
support and Military Support in the in
the year ahead or the months ahead and
Republican voices are starting to speak
out uh we had we've had Kevin McCarthy
who is the house representative
representative speaker and also going to
santis who's the Republican senator of
Florida who
um is likely or a possible uh
presidential candidate uh next time
around let's not forget of course that
Joe Biden is up for re-election uh if he
decides to go for it as seems to be the
case at the moment despite his spiked
his age uh shortly
they're they're suggesting that actually
the you they're questioning the US's
ability to continue providing sustaining
that sort of long-term support and this
is obviously said against a backdrop in
the states of a declining public support
for the conflict in Ukraine at that time
obviously the cost of living crisis and
inflation inflationary pressure on
households in quite stark contrast
contrast to What's Happening Here in the
UK the polls suggests that from the very
beginning of the conflict a year ago
there was very high support for
um for Ukraine and the U.S continuing to
provide Financial ability support that
has dropped off quite dramatically
whereas in the UK there is still this um
overwhelming public support for for
backing them so the is a domestic
pressures on Biden regardless of what
his his uh sort of his intention is but
politically and also you know the US's
role in the world stage and of the
sphere of Russia in all of this and and
the the sort of the ongoing tension that
exists between the states and Russia so
um it's not just International
considerations there's also the domestic
ones the U.S has to consider as well
Daily Telegraph um Harry with uh
choosing to use a slightly awkward hug
photo between the two presidents on
President's Day in fact Joe Biden and
the U.S president but the main story for
them is that Liz truss and Boris Johnson
are now saying that fighter jets should
go
um Liz truss um I understand and you
correct me if I'm wrong with her first
intervention as a backbencher since 2012
when she was a appointed a minister is
that right
that is correct and it was actually a
pretty good speech um given that
speeches aren't necessarily a strong
point
um it was uh it was very passionate she
you know it was quite out there she made
it very clear that she supports
alongside Boris Johnson this call for
Britain to send Jets there was no
beating about the bush uh there it was
um it was quite powerful stuff because
obviously as former Prime Ministers you
get to both
um you sort of go very high up the
pecking order in a debate so you have
the sort of government slide and then
the opposition line then you had two
former Prime Ministers both really
really holding the government's feet to
the fire to go further in support uh
with two pretty good speeches actually
and the telegraph back into their
natural comfort zone of saying those
things about this trust and Boris
Johnson
well lots more coverage of of Ukraine
and those big questions too um Joe Biden
as we said Landing in uh Warsaw just a
short time ago he'll be making a big
speech there meeting the Polish
president as well and the so-called
Bucharest nine the leaders of these
central European nations that are
closest to Russia of course worth
remembering that President Putin will
make his own speech tomorrow as well so
certainly a big day for those
positioning uh with the anniversary
looming for the Ukraine war but those
very latest pictures of Joe Biden
descending the steps of Air Force One as
he makes his way into Central Warsaw
people let's move on shall we
um now then the Northern Ireland
protocol a sense that things might be
happening I know you were sort of
calming things down earlier today don't
jettison the Northern Ireland protocol
this is now sort of Braven warning I
think Boris Johnson had earlier one too
but when are we expecting to to hear
more about this and uh what might happen
the brexit deal May trigger resignations
that the time's telling us
yeah well we obviously all got into uh
all were very excited about this at the
end of last week when Rishi sinak uh
turned up in Belfast to speak to the
northern land political parties while
actually speak to the dup but of course
he met the others as well
um and then of course there was comments
over the weekend about getting closer to
a deal
um with the European commission I do
think it surprises anyone particularly
that a technocratic managerial prime
minister might reach some sort of uh
shared ground I might have some shared
ground on which he could strike a deal
with the with with the technocratic
managerial Brussels the difficult part
of this for all of this for him is going
to be the political aspect of it and
getting it past his troops at home
um and uh while I think we're not there
yet with the deal Mario from the
commission and James cleverley our
foreign secretary had meetings this
afternoon at the end of which they said
they would meet again in coming days so
you know we had wondered whether there
might be a deal presented tomorrow I
think that's not like cleaner in the
next few days
um it's it's definitely the case that
the sort of the political workings are
going on at home which is when I spent
lots of time in his Commons office today
talking to Tory brexit here MPS to try
and make sure that they didn't Scupper
it when they announce it the dup I'm
told isn't going to get a sort of an
advanced notice of of a um of a draft
the text this is a deal obviously with
the commission rather than with dup but
um but uh you know the plenty of people
in the conservative party and Beyond to
think that uh that's unwise not to
include them but to make sure that they
were on board because of course they
have the capacity to blow this whole
thing apart
um and uh you know it's a real test for
Cenac isn't it he wants to be able to do
he wants to be able to say that he has
moved on move the country on from brexit
and being able to concentrate on the
dividends rather than sort of the
wrangling the negotiations whether he'll
be able to do that I think this week is
going to be very telling yes and
critical to it is where should that
border go
um you know should it be in the ROC
should it be in a soft border towards
the Republic of Ireland and does sunak
jump towards the ERG and the dup or does
he jump towards the European Union where
do you think he'll land Harry there's
there's no there's no hope in Hell of
the Border moving anywhere other than
the Irish seats but how they it's how
they utilize it can they for the 90 of
the goods that go from the Great Britain
Mainland to into the Northern Ireland
into the province that stay in Northern
Ireland can they be extracted from
burdensome burdens have been actually
some overzealous EU checks which we've
done to prove a point to make this as
difficult possible and frankly give the
UK a bit of a punishment beating
believing
um is there a way of of easing that
pressure while also unlocking the the
the political tensions in Northern
Ireland where the dep say get rid of
these rules completely or we're not
coming back to Stormont is there a way
that it can land somewhere halfway
between the two I think the best let's
see that could hope for is the dep don't
say no if they they're not going to say
yes I they they rarely do but if they
actually say look fine show us how it
works in practice
I think that's quite a big win if they
can get this protocol deal agreed with
the EU implement it and allow to see how
it works see if those checks come down
you know we'll probably wait to the
first dispute but then how does that
work will the European judges have to
get involved or can it be done by North
in Northern Irish courts I think this is
it we're in for the long run you know
the easiest part I think for this is
going to be getting the deal as Pippa
says and actually selling it to Norm to
the Northern Ireland communities on both
sides of the Divide
um it's gonna remain very hard of course
the time is saying tomorrow that there's
going to be political resignations you
know especially soon that bought half
the ERG into government in order to try
and neutralize them and as we've seen
before in this brexit process they're
not afraid to walk away sometimes from
lucrative government jobs if they think
that there's a sellout I can think of a
few high-profile names Steve Baker for
example is in the Northern Ireland
office who is a you know extremely
passionate brexiteer and a purist on
this stuff he's not going to sit there
for the sake of it if he doesn't think
the government are doing the right thing
so yeah as Pippa said first big test for
sunac he's done everything in the first
three months in office to try and calm
things down not have a fight with a
party not ever fight with his MPS I
think he can't escape a fight with some
of his party on this stuff and um let's
see what he's made up let's let's test
his metal okay uh just a very quick word
if you don't mind uh on The Daily Star
Roald Dahl should words be changed words
like fat and ugly we are told now some
pointing out that already some of the
text has been adapted over the decades
um but certainly people are speaking out
on this pepper
yeah I was flicking through my own copy
of The BFG earlier
um obviously we're big fans of it in
this house with lots of children we've
we've read all of them on multiple
occasions and the Publishers and Netflix
uh they've all done the state have
decided that they want to make some
small changes and some of them kind of
make sense I mean anything which which
could overtly be regarded as racist or
uh misogynist I mean fair enough but
there's lots of what they describe as
small changes which you know frankly
seem like a stretch too far
um things like removing any references
to the word fat even though that's what
they're talking about with Augustus
kalupin Charlie the Chocolate Factory
um and uh you know Tara songs Rewritten
in James the giant peach new sentences
added in the witches which explain what
there might be a myriad of reasons why
people choose to wear wigs you know I
mean I think one of the points about
Roald Dahl and the beauty of him is that
it's actually some of the stuff in there
is quite mean and nasty and that's what
kids like about it because you know he's
says things that lots of children's
authors don't and of course he has a com
he was a complex man there was some real
issues with some of his views his estate
apologized a couple of years ago some of
the anti-Semitism
um that he had displayed in the past but
as far as the books go I think fair
enough if anything is like really
obviously effortly offensive but also
give some people credit and let
children's imaginations flourish okay
Harry I know y'all want to talk about it
do it next time a bit later on but both
of you stay there oh yes exactly lots
more still to come we'll take a further
look at the newspapers including
confirmation that the body found in the
river was that of Nicola bully
[Music]
thank you
well welcome back you're watching the
Press preview with me now paper career
and Harry Cole from the guardian and the
son welcome back to both of you and uh
your paper Harry
um amongst many others as well leading
on the really devastating news for
Nicola Bully's family
yeah um a grim day that was the
inevitability about it from yesterday
when that body was discovered
um not by the police but by a member of
the public
um an awful an awful conclusion to um to
the story and now it's awful the more
longer wait for the coroners report and
it goes on I think once the dust settles
on this though I do think
um Lancashire police need to have a long
hard look in the mirror
Peppa
well it's a terribly sad terribly sad
day isn't it for the family and you know
they've not just had to deal with their
their mother their wife their daughter
going missing but they've also had to
deal with a huge amount of speculation
on social media amateur sleuths turning
up and the police really conducting a
very sort of
um sort of up and down investigation it
feels like from the outside and that
they've been saying one thing one day
and something else a couple of days
later they talked about her own uh
personal troubles which obviously
attracted a lot of criticism
um and uh you know big questions I think
tonight around the police's handling of
um of the whole search
um not least the fact that they very
early on it looks like their suggestion
that she that she's gone into the river
uh very early on
um uh was obviously proven right but
then they conducted this three-week
search up under the river with with
um with sonar with divers with
specialist teams coming in and they
didn't manage to find Jones Harry says
it was members of the public that did so
it must have been an agonizing time for
the family you can understand why they
are they are obviously extremely
distressed and upset with the media as
well as as well as you know some of the
people that have been turning up in
their Community they're very small
tight-knit
um Community
um and and presumably from their from
their perspective stirring things up but
I think tonight really you just need to
think about Nicola bully and those those
poor children and her husband who are
sitting at home
um finally know uh finally they're the
worst fears have been realized
um and you know they're understandably
heartbroken by the whole thing yes and
uh many of the newspaper front pages
picking up on that quote you have been
found we can let you rest now the uh the
statement there
um just a a quick mention of the Metro
if you can Harry Junior doctors now
72-hour walkout plan this is another big
one
yeah I think the Metro is only there
sums up that exact uh they can't really
decide what to do with that story can
they they know it's an important story
but they don't think that their readers
are going to be that interested in it
because they seem to have given it less
than a third of their front page so
you're kind of either going to do the
story properly or not Junior doctors
obviously have an interesting
relationship with this government Jeremy
Hunt now the chancellor the man who
could loosen the birth strings if he
wanted to almost made his name as health
secretary as a long dispute with the
junior doctors didn't blink to them and
I don't think they're going to Blink now
so it adds to a long list of
organizations and sectors that are
striking and doesn't seem to be having
the desired effect because the
government at the moment isn't moving
absolutely not it seems um Harry
Culpepper career thank you both very
much indeed thank you